right here now with reaction former
senior advisor to president Trump
Stephen Miller and former house Intel
committee chair Devin Nunes now the head
of Truth social Devin you went head to
head with him uh not only did he tell a
lie at day after day after day uh you
were proven correct in what you were
telling the public but even to this very
days clinging to the Russia hoax lie uh
in comments that he made earlier today
yeah he and he will still continue to do
that he's running for Senate in
California and now is actually in the
lead
I think everybody just has to take a
step back here and look at what really
happened you have a corrupt doj corrupt
FBI that worked with the Clinton
campaign to launch this to launch this
hoax that still continues today they got
away with it then and they're getting
away with it now and I think it's
getting worse and worse and you see it
and it's sad because you would hope that
those guys that got spared you were
playing them some of the FBI guys that
were involved in this hoax
you see them you see what they're saying
you would think this would be a time to
take a step back and notice hey Durham
didn't call me Durham didn't even
subpoena me I never had to answer any
questions but instead they're doubling
down they show No Remorse and I think
that's why you see many people in the
United States Congress and many people
all over America saying look the FBI is
hopelessly corrupted and I think that's
where it's at now and I think a lot of
people rightly are calling for the FBI
to be defunded and maybe you know a new
uh Premier law enforcement agency will
come up in its wake Stephen Miller
because unfortunately I I think it's
been so politicized and weaponized I'm
not sure you can even fix it at this
point
well let's not mince our words what you
saw in 2016 continuing out through the
entirety of the Trump presidency was a
coup by an unelected bureaucracy an
attempt to throw Donald Trump out of the
White House and then a continuing
sustained unrelenting attempt to
undermine his presidency every single
day he was in office and then to jail
his staff and his advisors from Mike
Flynn to Paul manafort and on down the
list and that effort now has now
continued and become this series of
prosecutions including the
investigations Now by doj for the
purpose of keeping him out of the white
house yet again these are the kinds of
tactics that you see in banana republics
in despotic regimes in failed third
world States the task of reforming the
security state and federal law
enforcement is a matter of survival for
American democracy to continue to be a
self-governing republic where the people
not the elites not the corrupt media and
not the corrupt bureaucracy choose our
leaders you know and Devin it continued
in 2020 I mean the FBI had Hunter
Biden's laptop in December 2019. John
Solomon says it was verified uh as
authentic in the spring of 2020 then why
were FBI agents in the months leading up
to the 2020 presidential election why
were they meeting weekly with big tech
companies warning them that they may be
victims of a misinformation campaign and
it may be about Joe Biden and even
Hunter Biden at least according to the
Missouri case which I have cited often
so is that any different are they not
putting cinder blocks on the scale of a
presidential election they knew that
this document would come out they knew
that Hunter's laptop would come out
because they knew Rudy Giuliani had a
copy of it
yeah look they hid that it was it was a
scheme it was no different than the rush
Oaks well they created the Russia hoax
because they thought the Russians or
someone else were going to release
Hillary Clinton's real emails which by
the way we never found nobody ever saw
them they were worried about that that's
why they created this this scheme 2020
they did the same thing and what they've
done is they've poisoned millions of
Americans Minds where you have so many
people out there that I bet shot if you
did a poll today you probably still have
half of America who still thinks that
Trump and Republicans have something to
do with Russia when the reality is the
only people have had anything to do with
Russia was Hillary and now you actually
harassment people shows that you know
the vast overwhelming majority of
Independents Republicans and almost 50
percent of Democrats see that uh things
would not run right in 2020 especially
in life
during the election
yeah during the election I think that
has broken through and I think that's
why you see the polls look really good
for Donald Trump but but still there is
a two-tier justice system in this
country and the republicans in Congress
have a hell of a job to do in the future
because I think you know not having a a
trustworthy doj and FBI is that Stephen
just said it leads to a Banana Republic
stuff you see in the third world oh
what's what's scheduled for 2024. the
accountability Sean there must be
accountability and that's the sad part
you know all these years later nobody's
being held accountable anyway Stephen
thank you Devin thank you coming up
damning new information on the Biden's
close ties to China including a possible
link between a Biden think tank and the
CCP John Levine and Greg Jarrett have
the very latest as we continue
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else